but what makes it geometric is that
you're multiplying by the same ratio the
same number to get to the next term so
I'm going to show you a formula we're
gonna be using here and that's this one
here a sub N equals a sub 1 times R to
the N minus 1 power a sub 1 is the first
term R is the ratio what you're
multiplying by and is whatever term you
want to find so if you want to find the
10th term N equals 10 and so on so going
back to this example here we're starting
at 3 and you can see N equals 1 means
this is our first term N equals 2 that
means that's the second term N equals 3
is the third and so on but a sub 1 means
that's the value of the first term a sub
2 see this is a little subscript it just
tells you that that's the term you're on
the second term the value of that term
is 6 and so on so if we wanted to find
the let's see one two three four fifth
term okay N equals five we would start
at three and we would multiply by two
once twice three times four times okay
why not five times
well we already started at three the
first term so we only had to multiply by
the common ratio - one less number of
times okay because we were already here
we just took four times that's where the
N minus one comes from and now the ratio
why do they call it a ratio they call it
a ratio because if you take this number
this term and you divided by the
previous term 24 divided by 12 equals to
12 divided by 6 equals two and six
divided by three equals two so if you
take the term divided by the one before
it that gives you the ratio and that's
what you're multiplying by to move
forward to the next term and so on so
say we want to find the 10th term well
we could keep multiplying by two okay
which that's one way to do it that's a
recursive way that would be like this a
sub 1 equals 3 a sub N equals a sub n
minus 1 that just means you go back to
the previous term and you add not add in
this case you're multiplying by 2 right
okay so that's a recursive way to write
the formula you keep going back one term
see and mine
one and then you multiply by two if you
want the sixth term you go back to the
six minus one the fifth term you
multiply by two but this is an explicit
formula it takes you right there and so
what you have is you have we want to
find the 10th term so we start off with
the first term which is three we're
multiplying by two nine times because
we're already at three to get to the
tenth term we just have to multiply one
less time and so this is just going to
be three times two to the ninth that's
the value of the tenth term now if you
were to plot these points like if we
were to draw this on a coordinate axis
so term number one is three term number
two is six term number three is twelve
and if you can see this it's going up at
a faster and faster rate this is
actually an exponential okay an
exponential curve whereas when we did
the arithmetic ones who is linear was
going up at a constant rate you kept
adding that common difference here we're
multiplying by the ratio and you can see
it looks like an exponential equation
that variable is in the exponent okay so
that's how you work with this when they
give you a list well what happens if
they just give you two terms like the
fifth term is 80 and the eighth term is
five fours
they tell us it's a geometric sequence
but find the 12th term hmm how do we
handle that well what we're going to do
is we're going to write a system of
equations so what we're going to do is
we're going to say the fifth term is 80
the first term we don't know the ratio
we also don't know but 5 minus 1 is 4
okay then we're going to say all right
the eighth term so the eighth term is
five fours we don't know the first term
we don't know the ratio but we know that
8 minus 1 is 7 so now we have two
equations ok two variables and we can
solve that system so what we're going to
do something maybe a little bit
different than you've seen before we're
going to actually divide so when we
divide see how the a 1s cancel one
another out seven minus four when you
divide and you have the same base you
subtract the exponents remember that so
it's R cubed equals 5/4 divided
by 80 when you divide by a fraction it's
like multiplying by the reciprocal so
this is five fourths times 180 I'm going
to reduce five goes in here once five
goes in here 16 times so this is one
sixty-fourth equals R cubed if you take
the cube root of both sides you can see
that R equals one-fourth okay okay so
now we know the ratio if we put it back
in to any one of these equations maybe
I'll just put it back into this one
right here we get eighty equals a sub
one 1/4 to the fourth power which is a
sub one times one over 256 if we
multiply both sides excuse me by 256 we
get the first term which is I want to do
that on the calculator real quick here
it's 80 times 256 20 thousand four
hundred and eighty twenty thousand four
hundred eighty so if we put it all back
together we've got a sub N equals the
first term just 20 thousand four hundred
and eighty okay
times the ratio which is one-fourth to
the N minus one power okay so this is
our formula our explicit formula if we
want to find the twelfth term a sub 12
all we have to do is put in 12 there